if a friend comes to you and they feel
like they failed at something what would
you tell them to change that perspective
of the word failure turn the loss into a
learning experience do it again until
you get it right period you never did
anything right the first time practice
makes perfect it's just like you ain't
gonna make a muscle the first time you
pick up a bar
you gotta
do it for a while then your blood pumps
and then you strong go get strong pull
your skirt up that's what i'm gonna say
i'm not gonna be nice about it i'm sick
of that everybody's depressed because
they're trying to fit into a puzzle
they're trying to be a circle in the
square and you you're told what to do
and you're told what to eat and you're
told what's good and bad and what the
perspective of success is success is
love success is your family success is
how much you lack i don't care how much
money you got in the bank if you got a
crooked smile if you're people around
you don't want to be around your breath
stinks and all of us
you're broke period right you're broke
if you have nothing to fight for you're
broke you have nothing to love you broke
period